[music]
>> They want to know how we know.
Bro never should have wrote what he
wrote. I hear we just [music] read.
Dropping quote after quote.
Now they steady trying to cope with no
hope. I hear we just [music] read.
>> [singing]
>> How do y'all be knowing so much?
We got scholars but nobody shows us.
>> [music]
>> Why you even reading all that?
If you ain't even believing all that.
We just read. We just read. This what
your book said. Don't blame me.
>> [music]
>> We just read. We just read. This what
your book said. Don't blame me. Hey,
here's [music] a challenge for you. Open
up your book. Can you read it and
explain to us how Allah ain't a crook? I
see you can make it pretty but it's not
about the look because the words and
what they mean is why you always getting
cooked. Easy mode. We just reading and
[music] relaying what was said. You
don't even read your book so you just
make it up instead. Y'all deny the one
who's been erased from the dead. Make us
sad because one day you have to pay for
what you said. How we know that it's a
lie? The many babies in your faith. How
we know Muhammad thought that he was
crazy and a fake. [music] How we know
that Allah even sending babies to the
lake. We just read and see your
scriptures in a paganistic state.
None of y'all can even understand the
trinity. Silly me, why would I expect to
see humility? We know you ain't read
[music] the Bible. You rely on GPT
that's done and cruel and a fake every
time you speak to me. They want to know
how [music and singing] we know.
Bro never should have wrote what he
wrote. I hear we just read. Dropping
quote after quote.
Now they steady trying to cope with no
hope. I hear we just read.
We just read. [music] We just read. This
what your book said. Don't blame me.
We just read. We just read. This what
your book said. [music] Don't blame me.
We know about Quran and we know about
Bible.